[Music]
the truth has been clear since the dawn
of man yet man has ignored it no longer
have faith that we can prepare you to
receive you strive for clarity and
anyone who lives in the San Francisco
Bay Area will feel right at home in
Watch Dogs 2o but I don't think you need
to be familiar with the real Bay Area to
appreciate how its mix of Nature and
urban sprawl makes for a picturesque and
playful open world whether or not you
understand the references that drive its
Twisted take on Silicon Valley shouldn't
matter either this outing airs on the
side of a reverence and Unapologetic fun
trading in the original watchdog's rain
soaked trenched coat and drab demeanor
for a pair of skinny jeans and neon
colored assault
rifles this ass WIP this gleeful
exterior masks a troubled Society in the
throws of gang violence corrupt
officials and rampant hacking our
anti-hero Marcus is to an extent part of
the problem but he's mostly on the side
of good with his hacking skills under
your control you spend a lot of time
thwarting nefarious jerks by tapping
into their networks to hit them where it
hurts and when digital attacks fail
Marcus knows how to handle a gun he is a
walking contradiction that hates
corruption and murders without flinching
but his actions are so entertaining that
you probably won't care for long you're
making your primary Mission stems from
dead SEC a group of stereotypical
occasionally overacted hackers who
Target government and corporate entities
that see private information as a
commodity with a phone in hand and the
help of a botn net derived from dead sex
social media followers you can
manipulate digital locks computers and
security cameras to steal data and spy
on unknowing victims time to mess with
the farmer clown sneaking around enemies
requires critical thought and precise
action but the more you play the more
you discover ways to work around the
heaviest hitters and enemy AI in
general it starts early on when you
learn how easy it is to distract a guard
by sending a fake call to their cell
phone even when they're searching for an
intruder in big numbers a group of
guards is difficult to manage and a few
missions will surprise you with tricky
layouts and hidden variables that force
you to consider a plan B Marcus is
remarkably fit but he's less graceful
when facing guards unfortunately due to
Sticky cover mechanics that don't always
react the way you hope it's not unusual
to find yourself on the wrong side of an
object because the game couldn't tell if
you wanted to around a corner or snap to
a different object
altogether it doesn't take long for the
police to show up when gunfire breaks
out and you can try to hold your ground
by hacking and firing back but even with
a heavy Arsenal you'll eventually have
to flee driving feels a bit all over the
place with only a few rides that offer a
pleasing balance of performance and
control the rest are too slow to be
useful or too wild to steer with
confidence Under Pressure Ubisoft does a
great job of presenting the Bay Area in
an attractive way that feeds in tripid
tourists with an impressive variety of
[Music]
sites however something's definitely
missing you won't see a lot of
pedestrians or cars on the street
compared to similar games on one hand
this limits how much destruction you can
create but it also gives you space to
drive fast in a city that's usually
clogged with traffic we're going to mess
with the
cops oh
man is that
the the ladder is important not only for
sightseeing but also because it gives
you a better chance of running into mini
gamess you can always check your map and
fast travel to Mission icons or curious
events but that deprives you of the
rewarding sense of Discovery Watchdogs 2
affords
you're never far from a motorcycle or
go-kart race or a handful of small side
missions there's no shortage of wacky
quests to break things up and offer
light-hearted goals such as rescuing a
Tom cruik celebrity from the clutches of
a cult okay there are rumors about this
place where they take church members who
are having issues or hijacking a talking
car similar to Kit from Night
Rider system check Sweet let's
roll though the feature wasn't present
at launch Watchdogs 2 now support
seamless player versus player hacking
online and knowing that you may have to
stop what you're doing at the drop of a
hat to find a nearby stranger tapping
into your phone as a small but
appreciable layer to the experience when
you'd rather hack with rather than
against someone you can take on small
Co-op missions with a partner but
they're so close to single player
missions and structure that factoring in
coordination can seem like a chore
rather than a benefit even when playing
alone Watch Dogs 2 remains a fun
energetic game filled with possibilities
it's easy to pull coals in its narrative
and see- through enemy AI during
missions that are supposed to be
challenging which can hold back the game
at large but it's also a chance to let
loose logic be damned it's a step up
from the last game overall and even
though Watchdogs 2 can't go toe-to-toe
with other open world heavyweights it's
hard to walk away from its fun-loving
attitude and exuberant cast yeah let's
do
[Music]
this